hello I'm Patty Brennan director of the
National Library of Medicine in fact we
are all in a sense Patty Brennan thanks
to the technology such as the one that
generated this video and helped develop
this text the healthcare experience is
being reimagined with artificial
intelligence as a partner for clinicians
researchers and patients we're at an
extraordinary Time full of promise and
risks
research is needed to help realize the
promise of AI for health for all
responsible regulation is necessary both
to mitigate significant risks and to
create an environment for Effective
innovation
time to be at a library because the data
researchers collect and make available
is no longer simply an artifact of what
was discovered or known but is now the
substrate of what's going to be
discovered or needs to be known
now let me turn over to the real Patty
Brennan